how to write a business plan for
investors a lot of entrepreneurs come in
with this kind of question that came in
recently from one of my YouTube viewers
beauty box beauty box wrote in to say
I'm a new subscriber Evan I'm a recent
graduate with a great business idea my
major was in business I'm having
difficulty putting together business
plan do you have a generic template I
can use or Norva site where I can get
one thank you when you're approaching
investors okay I don't know if you're
going after angel investors or friends
and family or a bank or whatever it is
it doesn't have to be complicated okay a
business plan does not have to be super
complicated you don't have to have a
business degree don't don't let that
hold you back just because you don't
have a business degree you think I can't
write a great business plan okay what it
has to do is make sense if you go to any
bank website any major bank they'll have
templates there they'll have templates
of business plans that you can look at
and see how the structure it the
structure is not as important as the
content and as long as it makes sense an
investor is going to look at it and make
a decision based on that
remember investors are not experts in
your field they are not experts in the
beauty business they're generalists they
want to see that you're gonna be able to
make them money or if it's a loan to pay
back that loan I used to be in the
venture capital business and here are
the three things that I looked at first
three things these are the three things
that I looked at before make a decision
to bring in a company and give them
money or not okay the very first thing
is the executive summary that's the one
or two pages at the beginning of your
business plan that explains in basic
English what it is that you do and so
many entrepreneurs get this wrong most
of the business ones that I saw got
trashed because the executive summary
was was terrible if you don't do a good
job an executive summary it doesn't
matter how great a business plan you
have nobody's gonna read it because you
didn't sell them on the executive
summary so that one page is critical has
everything that somebody needs to know
about the opportunity ahead of them okay
the one thing that that we always look
for is that it passed the grandmother
test okay this was the term news
I guess in the VC world is it so simple
to understand that your grandmother can
understand it because too many
entrepreneurs put jargon and short forms
and technical terms that the investors
they don't understand that and it makes
sense to you you read a say yeah that's
what we do of course how do you not
understand that but it doesn't make
sense to the average person so make sure
that you give your executive summary to
a person who has no idea what your
business is all about a layman because
if they can understand it and see the
opportunity then you're ready to bring
it to investors so it's the most
important first step get the executive
summary down the next thing they're
going to look at is your financials they
want to see how much money do you need
what's it going to be used for and how
much money are they going to make back
different types of investors have
different criteria if you're looking to
go to a bank they don't want to see
massive huge returns they want to they
want the security that they're gonna
make their money back
if you're going to an angel investor
they want to see that you're gonna be
making thirty percent a year on their
money because they want an exit from
this so they want to see high growth if
you're a low cost low margin low growth
type of business that's not gonna work
with an angel investor so you've got to
make sure that the financials make sense
for the person that you're talking to
the next thing and the last thing you
look for before making a decision to
read the whole business plan is the team
who is behind this company there's an
expression in the VC world again called
horse for the course meaning are you the
right person to be at the head of this
company and make this opportunity happen
because you could be in a great market
but if you're not the right person
you're not gonna be successful and you
can be in a crappy market but if you are
the right person you can still build a
great company so they want to learn
about the management team who are you
and the biggest thing that most
entrepreneurs fall down on here is they
have lack of startup experience
investors and bankers they want to see
that you have done this before
or you have people on your team who've
done this before and quite often on a
management team there's nobody there
it's just you
and you've never done it before and so
these are like big strikes against you
so yeah I'm gonna risk my money with
this person I don't think so one way to
combat this is to you can either look
for partners so bring on people who who
have more experience who can compliment
you but if you don't want to give up
equity you're not quite sure to
partnership relationship yet create a
Board of Advisors and these are people
who've had some experience have some
success they don't have any equity in
your business it's it's kind of a loose
term but they're willing to lend their
name to the business and an advisor
could be structured where you meet them
every month and you have coffee talk
about it or it could be that you you
know it's loose and every six months you
have a phone call as long as they're
willing to help you and lend their name
to the project because if a banker or an
investor looks at your management team
and they see you with no experience no
partners you've never done it before
they're thinking I'm gonna lose all my
money so reduce that risk separate
yourself from everybody else bring on
the Board of Advisors talk to people
even if it's your lawyer or your
accountant even just putting their names
on there to say they're advisers you've
already separated yourself from most of
the other people who are presenting and
giving their business plans in because
it shows that you value and trust the
expertise of other people who can help
you build this thing up okay if you pass
those three things they're gonna look to
the rest of the business plan and see if
they want to make a decision to bring
you in invest in you or whatever okay
the actual templates are not hard to
find
again any bank website will have sample
templates but the templates is a good
starting point to give you an idea of
the sections but really the meat of it
is gonna come from having an executive
summary that makes sense
financials that make sense that a tailor
to the person you're talking to and then
having a management team / Board of
advisers that give the investor some
sense of security that they give you
money you're not gonna go lose it all
thank you for the great question you
have any more questions let me know
believe for those of you watching like
the video give it a thumbs up if you
have a comment about this video or you
want me to expand
things I talked about leave a question
below in the comments I make a video
response thank you so much and I'll see
you soon